quel monde après la crise planétaire du
coc vide 19 baisse de la pollution de
l'air de la consommation en énergie
et si demain nous revoyons notre rapport
à l'eau au gaz à l'électricité depuis
des décennies des citoyens optent pour
l'autosuffisance énergétique
à l'image de patrick et brigitte
baronnet voici leur maison en 1997 que
vous voyez ici on a une éolienne
on a un chauffe eau solaire qui nous
permette d'avoir de l'électricité en
permanence le hiver comme été jour comme
nuit ainsi que de l'eau chaude en
permanence également depuis 1997 le
couple vit en autosuffisance énergétique
ils produisent même trois fois plus
d'énergie qu'ils n'en ont besoin le
couple a quitté paris pour la
loire-atlantique en 1976 et petit à
petit ils ont développé leur propre
outil de production d'énergie si moi qui
suis professeur d'éducation physique et
professeur de yoga qui ne suis pas
spécialiste dans la question a réussi ça
je pense qu'il ya suffisamment
d'ingénieurs qui aurait pu trouver ça
bien avant ce mode de vie hors du commun
indépendant à la fois écologique et
économique inspire les curieux de toute
la france
ce que je recherche actuellement c'est
plutôt à avoir un système peu coûteux en
1999 le couple tente de créer un éco
village avec des nouveaux venus
mais le voisinage ne semble pas tout à
fait prêt nous nous considérons nous
comme des écologistes mais nous voulons
pas faire changer les esprits des autres
en attendant patrick baronnet a trouvé
un autre moyen d'échanger autour de ces
pratiques
il crée en 2000 ans l'éco festival une
centaine d'exposants avec un public
d'abord constitué de militants et de
décroissants qui s'est diversifié en
quelques années c'est plus des écolos
qui auront leurs capteurs solaires leurs
éoliennes
le but c'est que tout le monde puisse
accéder à des prix raisonnables et c'est
possible à l'écologie
depuis 2010 les baronets ne sont plus
seuls ils ont réussi leur pari dans
éco-hameau trois familles en 2018
toujours en autonomie énergétique on
avait une maison à crédit ont failli à
nos énergies et puis finalement on
n'était pas heureux parce qu'on on avait
l'impression de courir après le temps et
puis ne pas prendre le temps avec nos
enfants ne pas pouvoir profiter de tout
ça l'autonomie énergétique l'idée a fait
du chemin
c'est désormais une réalité pour des
communes entières comme béganne en
bretagne où les citoyens se sont à 10
pour acheter leur propre éolienne
[Musique]